adblock has been taking away billions of
dollars from Google every single year
yet Google has never taken any steps to
stop adblock in fact one of the most
popular blogging services is found on
the Google Chrome store yet goo has
never attempted to block the extension
furthermore ad blocking is not a small
issue either in 2017 us publishers alone
lost fifteen point eight billion dollars
due to ad blocking with over a quarter
of users in the u.s. using some sort of
ad blocking service considering this why
as google stayed silent but before we
get into that let's get a better
understanding of how adblock even works
in basic terms adblock simply filters
all requests to display something on a
particular web site and blocks a request
as say two related to advertising ad
blocking services uses list of domains
that are most involved in serving ads
and block any requests from these
domains users can often add domain
serious lists or even block certain
aspects of a given website like social
media buttons given the simplicity of
the service it wouldn't take very long
for Google to bypass these services or
simply take them down altogether the
reason Google doesn't do this starts
with how they make money with ads Google
only makes money when a user clicks on
an ad not when it is simply shown on the
back end many advertisers bid on
keywords and audience demographics this
bid is the amount of money and
advertisers willing to pay per click
from the user in the end only the
highest bidder is actually shown to the
audience and the advertiser doesn't have
to pay Google till a user clicks on an
ad the thing is people who are so averse
to ads that they'll go after a way to
block them usually wouldn't click on the
ads anyway this is not to say that ads
would be 100% ineffective against this
demographic it's just that the
click-through rate would be much lower
furthermore by isolating this
demographic out and not showing them ads
that click-through rate for the average
user would be higher this higher
click-through rate will lead to
advertisers bidding higher and paying
more for each click as a click will be
more likely
on top of this this click revenue goes
to creators and owners of websites
Google takes 40% of ad revenue while 60%
goes to creators so the bulk of the
losses don't fall on Google of course
despite all of this
Google is losing billions buy ad lockers
however these points do decently offset
their losses moving on blocking ads
would go against their entire business
model if they blocked adblock whether a
movie the extension for the Chrome Web
Store or adding some sort of update that
would prevent a block from running a big
portion of the user base would leave and
all the money they have invested in this
user would be lost the thing is Google
loses the money in most of their
ventures believe it or not
YouTube has never been profitable for
Google and her losses are only getting
bigger as more users come watch the
platform this is the same case for most
of their free services like Google Mac's
Google Drive and where to google
playstore and so on and so forth now
Google has after several years made many
of these profitable but that was never
the goal you see Google doesn't care
about making money on most of their
products from the very beginning google
has been giving out crazy services for
free in an effort to get users to use
google.com whether overly generous email
and cloud space or a free streaming
platform Google isn't looking to make
money just garner users Google sees
these money-losing services as
investments and continue to keep them
afloat in order to grow the user base
eventually they hope that you will use a
cool calm where they can collect data
from you sell this data show you ads and
finally make a profit to this day this
is euros main source of revenue despite
the hundreds of sectors are delved into
Google's advertising revenue is what
makes up eighty three point three
percent of alphabets total and your
revenue if a group of Google users want
to use adblock to continue using Google
products Google is more than okay with
that they can still collect data on you
so ad lock users are not a complete loss
in revenue for Google their main goal is
to keep users on Google and
professing a bit of ad revenue for that
it's not an issue also even if users
continue to use to call services after
they stop adblock these users are more
likely to use Google services for
shorter periods of time the best example
of this would be YouTube a person who is
used to watch YouTube without ads may
spend less time watching YouTube if as
were forced onto them this would not
only hurt audience retention but also
impact the amount of data they can
collect on these users moreover blocking
adblock would severely hurt their
reputation which they have built over
the past two decades Google has scrapped
to come off as the friendly covering
that puts their customers first this is
why they offers so many services for
free the number one priority is for
users to use their services and trust
them and as people are starting to
become more cautious about data mining
blocking adblock were just severely hurt
trust in Google and will ultimately hurt
the company more than any lost revenue
due to adblock overall though adblock is
harmful to Google over the short term
blocking the service would have
long-term repercussions that Google
believes will be much worse and this is
what Google has yet to block adblock and
likely never will if you guys thought
this we explained why google allows
adblock major drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like see more
questions just like this one logically
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one